[Music]
i guess i haven't heard like really
great things about it i assume it's all
going to be nasty the other stuff i've
i've tried i've kind of like like fish
and chips no one's like oh
dude we're getting british food this
week yeah we just ordered some british
food well the plates that i saw passed
by looked good
so hopefully i'm excited though i'm down
for the challenge
[Music]
am i supposed to like dip it in the
sauce or something
the gravy it's like they took a
hard-boiled egg and then just put like
meat around it it's like thanksgiving
and then there's
just an egg in the middle here we go i
like that
i don't you don't like it oh man i like
all the spices with the meat
i like the stuffing i don't like the egg
it honestly it takes me back to like a
food that my grandfather made the meat
reminds me of stuffing so it's way too
soft for me
britain has not really won me over yet
welsh rare bit did i say it right so
much flavor on the
in the cheese garnish i like the salty
with the crunchy
delicious i need to figure out where to
get this i would have it again
it reminds me of like an upscale grilled
cheese uk is still not winning
but it's getting a little better a lot
better than the first one we had
cornish pasty i thought it looked like
an empanada it looks like a croissant
stuffed with
beef and vegetables it reminds me of
like a pot pie
i like this one because it reminds me of
a jamaican beef patty i can get down
with this one
cornwall england go ahead cornwall
[Applause]
we have a steak mushroom and guinness
pie
i love the chunks of meat just swimming
in gravy it smells
really good though the meat's really
good kind of reminds me of like an ox
tail
from like you know caribbean but
obviously less spice
i think it's pretty good i'm i'm getting
pretty sold on this
all of this is very filling it may not
look like american proportions but
i feel like the food is just more dense
yep the eccles cake with current and
raisin i never liked raisins
what about currants i don't know what
those are you're not up on your
current affairs look at that huh
bruh i like this one i like the big
grain
sugar on it i feel like it adds a good
texture on top of the gooey inside
the desserts are winning this is where
england did good
[Music]
so we have some british scones
um these ones are round shaped
ours are usually triangular the jam
smells so good the aroma
is it like in poor taste to dip your
scone in the tea
that's amazing clotted cream is
interesting it's like butter but more
sour
british food is definitely growing on
in the beginning i thought it was going
to be horrible awful
disgusting but i will say there are some
things that i've come to like
i came into this uh pretty skeptical of
british food i thought it might be gross
i wouldn't ever say it's really that bad
i can definitely see myself coming back
and knowing like
some specific things to try now versus
just
having no idea